don't sit too close to the screen Oh rot
your brain the idiots Lantern boy this
is a heck of a one to get - some years
ago back when I did a 10 worst episodes
of modern era Doctor Who which is a
video that's badly out of date but I am
really not in the mood to update or do a
new version of but anyway at the time
I'm pretty sure I put this episode as my
number one worst or if I didn't put it
there at the very least I know I put the
wire as my number one worst one-time
villain so like I have a strong
pervasive long-standing dislike of this
episode on a lot of levels but coming
into it with that perspective I was
actually kind of excited to revisit it
not that I thought it would suddenly be
good but what I've learned doing this
series and giving a rewatch often times
to episodes that I haven't seen in a
while is that I can spot the things that
are good that I didn't remember I didn't
notice and there is some of that here
there is some good stuff going on it
doesn't save the episode not even close
but let's talk about that first
so the rapport between Tennant and Rose
it keeps building and I like the way
it's funny I'm realizing now how there's
a there's a pretty solid arc of their
interactions and the building of sort of
they're very cavalier attitude about
what they do and where they go and what
they encounter that does ultimately come
back to bite them at the end of the
series of spoilers no come on
but it is interesting to sort of see
that at play here it gets called out by
Queen Victoria in the second episode and
to see it keep playing out it's like
yeah you guys really
you know these these are serious
situations needed life-or-death
situations and you treat it like it's a
game and an end but at the same time it
is easy to get wrapped up in the fun
that these two are having so that is
kind of cool but I like that there is
ultimately going to be consequences for
that because if there weren't that then
it will grade on me how Cavalier they
are about all this I'm pretty sure I've
used that word now twice in a video and
that's twice more that I probably used
in the last year that's funny so we get
little fun touches like the fact that
the TARDIS still doesn't land well or
when the doctor thinks it's going to and
I oh I will always enjoy that so that's
good stuff
the some of the performances are
actually pretty solid and despite how
much to my memory I hated the wire the
actress who performs it is actually
pretty well cast and really suited to
the part the problem is and I'm gonna
just start getting into the bad stuff
now sorry the part is horrific Lee
written because the reason she's good
for it is that she has that sort of
friendly almost motherly tone that you
would want for for a character like this
who's trying to evoke that era of
television and so when she is in this
very pleasant voice you know laying out
her intentions or being maniacal but
doing it in this comp let's are you
sitting comfortably voice it really
works the problem is is that once we get
to the halfway point basically all she
says is and god I hate it it's so
repetitive it's so hammy and it is such
an under utilization and completely
misses what was working about the
character prior to that we go from the
great juxtaposition of her maliciousness
versus her her way of communicating in
terms of you know the way she spoke in
the character is a
and that now gets completely wiped out
for this generic crap oh it's awful and
then the other the other thing that
sinks it aside from that is one might
argue the problem the proper villain of
the piece at least as much as the wire
which is the father of this family now
it's not a bad idea to zero in on a
family so that we have real personal
stakes because you know it's always a
risk whenever you go this could take
over the whole of London or the world
like if we don't have a point of
reference for like what that means
that's a very abstract concept so giving
us a family to focus on is not a bad
idea
this father though and I've seen I
because I've railed on him before I
think two things I think the writing is
incredibly lazy and I think the
performance is terrible now I've had
people push back on me want to pointed
that out before saying that note there
are especially around that time people
like that men like that coming off the
war and feeling like they had to be the
king of their castle that it is
representative of something that did
exist and the thing is when I call it
cartoonish which it is that doesn't mean
that no people like that ever existed
I could call a you know a depiction of
somebody from the South you know in the
u.s. going
oh well shucks y'all ain't from around
here are you as being cartoonish it
doesn't mean you couldn't find me human
being who he actually thinks or talks
are acts like that but it doesn't make
it any more believable in terms it comes
across as one-dimensional because if
you're gonna have a character that
surface-level who is that immediately
just one thing and this guy is just a
jerk when you have someone who is just
that much of one thing and unless you
take the time to reveal that there's
anything underneath that it's going to
be cartoonish it's going to be
oversimplified and because he drives so
much of the plot and so many things keep
coming back to him he just keeps
undercutting what's going on over and
over and over again and again I think I
think the the writing is lazy
this isn't me saying like he needed
to have you know a Redemption target
I'll kind of come back to that hang on
to that thought but the there's sort of
the I'm not saying that like oh he
should have he should have been more you
know understanding we should have gotten
his perspective no I'll accept that he's
a jerk but like the there's no sense of
humanity anywhere under that and I don't
think you automatically weaken a
villainous character by giving them
humanity I think it's some ways that can
make a monster more monstrous when you
realize they are overriding the human
parts of them that are still there and
continuing to advocate like this when
you don't show that and all you've got
is the surface level jerker II then they
come across as just not very human
characters and I do think the
performance doesn't help I'm sorry when
he keeps going oh yeah I'm talking I
just I don't buy it I don't buy it for
an instance and again maybe it's
cultural maybe if I grew up in that area
maybe I would have met and known people
like that maybe I could relate to it I
didn't I can't I'm sorry I can only talk
about the perspective that I have and my
perspective is that this guy is a joke
he's a Jimmy he's a joke of a human
being yes but he's also a joke of a
character and considering he's trying to
work as a pizza as a part of the drama
it does not function at all and coming
back to what I said before about
redemption I I had completely forgotten
about this and not re watching it gives
me all the more reason to hate this
episode I hate that at the very end is
wife has effectively kicked him out of
the house good his sons prepared to
write him off at the very least for the
time being
Andros says go to him because he's your
dad and it's framed like this is a good
thing and I I wanted to just reach into
the TV and smack rose in the back side
of the head no like
it's one of the things that and again I
I'm not gonna say that this is like
whatever an intentional conspiratorial
undercurrent but so much media pushes
this idea of well they're your family
you gotta love them like no you don't if
somebody is that toxic that hazardous
that dangerous to your life I don't care
if it's your father I don't care if it's
your brother I don't care if it's your
kid you are within your rights to cut
them out and nobody has any business
saying well no you got to go to him cuz
he's your dad no screw you rose I
understand you've got your own baggage
because you didn't know your own dad so
I do get where that's coming from a
little bit and I'm not so I know I said
screw you rose I'm actually not so mad
at the character I'm mad at the episode
for framing it like that's a good idea
it's not best-case scenario he needs
time and distance from the sky and that
guy needs time and distance from his
family so that he understands the
consequences of what he did if he gets
thrown out of the house but then
immediately his sounds like it's okay
I'm still here for you
that immediately diminishes the
consequences that he's suffering he's
not gonna feel like he's suffering all
that much he's gonna lose what little
impetus there was for him to ever change
because I do believe that people can
change but you know what is a big part
of change self-reflection and what this
guy needs is to be is to be cut off and
isolated for a chunk of time so that he
can think about stuff you don't send his
kid right back to him after that
Wow that I got really I got a lot more
worked up about that than I was planning
to but like it really it really ticked
me off and the thing was up until the
point that that happened I was prepared
to say you know what this episode is not
good but it's not as bad as I used to
bag on it but then that happened I went
oh my god it is at least as bad as I
used to bag I'm on it just for a reason
other than what I used to bag on it for
but I think the reasons I've always been
down on this episode is still there I
think both villainous characters are
poorly written and in the case of the
father
badly performed and it's a shame because
there are potent ideas the faceless
people is a pretty cool image I'm not
sure the effect actually looks that
great a fair amount of the time but it's
it's a decent enough idea it's an
unsettling visual like I said the woman
cast as the wire was good for it until
the writing completely fell out from
under her the doctor getting a bit more
vicious I I liked pretty well he
delivers it decently I do I do feel like
Tennant gets maybe a little more sharp
and his delivery when he does that then
I would care for it but that's a
personal preference thing so I'm not
even gonna hold that against anything
but like like so many things there are
good components here that are completely
undercut undermined and fall apart under
the weight of what doesn't work and yeah
I still hate this episode I think this
is just terrible and I know it gets lost
in the conversation particularly around
series 2 because this is the same series
that has fear her and love and monsters
crap I got those coming up soon oh boy
but I feel like the how bad this episode
is gets lost in the shuffle because it's
not as me mobile as the absorbe all off
or you know a scribble monster but I
think I mean I'll have this hypothesis
tested in a couple weeks I do think it
is at least as bad and now at this point
bad in a way that actually makes me
angry we shouldn't use to be the case
funnily enough so the idiots Lantern man
okay I'm alright what do you think about
this one whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about this whole bunch of links down
there as well including one to the
patreon if you feel like supporting this
channel in that fashion it's been
growing it's it is a big help literally
any amount does help but there's a whole
bunch of other links down there besides
that you can check out if you want to
you don't want to look at those that's
okay too because at the end of the day
folks you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]